we proposed in my team actually that the
sun is is a is the ultimate Pinnacle of
telescope design but flying to a
thousand Au is a real pain in the butt
because it's just going to take so long
and so a more practical way of achieving
this maybe to use the Earth
now the Earth doesn't have anywhere near
enough gravity to create a substantial
gravitational lens but it has an
atmosphere and an atmosphere refracts
light it bends light so whenever you see
a sunset
um just as the sun setting below the
Horizon it's actually already Beneath
The Horizon it's just the light is
bending through the atmosphere it's
actually already about half a degree
down beneath and what you're seeing is
is that is that curvature of the light
path and your brain interprets of course
to be following a straight line because
your brain always thinks that
um and so you can use that bending
whenever you have bending you have a
telescope and so we've proposed to my
team that you could use this refraction
to similarly create an earth-sized
telescope called the terrascope the
tyroscope yeah a great video Yeah and uh
does you have a paper on the terrascope
I do yeah great um sometimes get
confused this because they've heard of
an earth-sized telescope because if they
may have heard of The Event Horizon
telescope which took an image of
um it was taking an image right now at
the center of our black hole and it's
very impressive and it previously did
Messi 87 a nearby super massive black
hole and so those images were
interferometric so they were small
telescopes scattered across the Earth
and they combined the light paths
together interferometrically to create
effectively an earth-sized
um angular resolution telescopes always
have two properties there's the angular
resolution which is how small of a thing
you can see on the surface and then
there's the magnification how much
brighter does that object get versus
just your eye or some small object now
what were the Event Horizon telescope
did it traded off
um amplification or magnification for
for the angular resolution that's what
it wanted it wanted that high angle
resolution but it doesn't really have
much Photon collecting power because
each telescope individually is very
small the terrascope is different
because it is literally collecting light
with a with a light bucket which is
essentially the size of the Earth and so
that gives you both benefits potentially
not only the high angular resolution
that a large aperture promises you but
also actually physically collects all
those photons so you can detect light
from very very far away through the
outer edges of the Universe
um and so we yeah we propose this as a
possible future uh technological way of
achieving these these extreme
goals ambitious goals we have in
astronomy but um it's a very difficult
system to test because you essentially
have to fly out to these Focus points
and these Focus points lie beyond the
moon so you have to have
someone who is willing to fly beyond the
moon and hitchhike an experimental
telescope onto it and do that cheaply if
it was something doing low earth orbit
it'd be easier you could just attach a
cubesat to the next Falcon 9 rocket or
something and test it out it probably
only cost you a few tens of thousands
dollars maybe a hundred thousand dollars
but there's basically no one who flies
out that far except for uh bespoke
missions such as like a mission that's
going to Mars or something that would
that would pass through that kind of
space and they typically don't have a
lot of leeway in excess payload that
they're willing to strap on for radical
experiments so that's been the problem
with it in theory it should work
beautifully but it's a very difficult
idea to experimentally test can you
elaborate where the focal point is that
far away
so you get about half a degree Bend from
the Earth's atmosphere
um when you're looking the Sun at the
Horizon and you get that two times over
if you're outside of the planet's
atmosphere because it comes you know the
star is half a Bend to use on the
horizon then half a degree back out
either way so you get about a one degree
Bend you take the rates of the earth
which is about seven thousand kilometers
and do your arctan function you'll end
up with a distance that's about two it's
actually the the inner focal points
about two-thirds the distance of the
Earth Moon system the problem with that
inner focal point is not useful because
that light Ray path had to basically
scrape the surface of the Earth so it
passes through the clouds it passes
through all the thick atmosphere gets a
lot of Extinction along the way
if you go higher up in altitude you get
less Extinction in fact you can even go
above the clouds and so that's even
better because the clouds obviously
going to be a pain in the neck for doing
anything Optical but the problem with
that is that the atmosphere because it
gets thinner at higher altitude it bends
light less and so that pushes the focal
point out so the most useful focal point
is actually about three or four times
the distance of the Earth Moon
separation and so that's what we call
one little garage points essentially out
there and so there was a stable orbit
it's kind of the outermost stable orbit
you could have around the Earth
um so the atmosphere
uh does bad things to to the signal yeah
it's absorbing light
um is that possible to reconstruct this
the to to remove the noise whatever so
it's just strength it's not nothing else
it's possible to reconstruct I mean to
some degree we do this as a technology
called Adaptive Optics that can correct
for what's called wavefront errors that
happen through the Earth's atmosphere
the Earth's atmosphere is turbulent it
is not a
single plane of air of the same density
there's all kind of Wiggles and currents
in the air and so that each little layer
is uh bending light in in slightly
different ways and so the light actually
kind of follows a wiggly path on its way
down what that means is that
um two light rays which are traveling at
slightly different spatial separations
from each other will arrive at the
detector at different times because one
maybe goes on more or less a straight
path and the one Wiggles down a bit more
before it arrives and so you have an
incoherent
um light source
um and when you're trying to image
reconstruction you always want a
coherent light source so the way they
correct for this is that this if this
path had to travel a little bit faster
uh the straight one goes faster and the
wiggly one takes longer the mirror is
deformable and so you actually bend the
mirror on this on the on the straight
one down a little bit to make it an
equivalent light path distance so the
mirror itself has all these little
actuators and it's actually made up of
like thousands of little elements almost
looks like a liquid mirror because they
can manipulate it in kind of real time
and so they scan the atmosphere with a
laser beam to tell what the deformations
are in the atmosphere and then make the
corrections to the mirror to account for
it that's amazing so you could you could
do something like this for the terrorist
group but it would be
um it's cheaper and easier to go above
the atmosphere and just fly out I think
so it would be very it's a very that's a
very challenging thing to do and
normally when you do Adaptive Optics as
it's called you're looking straight up
so you're you know or very close to
straight up if you look at the Horizon
we basically never do astronomical
observations on the horizon because
you're looking through more atmosphere
the if you go straight up you're looking
at the thinnest portion of atmosphere
possible but as you go closer and closer
towards the horizon you're increasing
what we call the air mass the amount of
air you have to travel through so here
it's kind of the worst case because
you're going through the entire
atmosphere in and out again with a
terror scope so you'd need a very
impressive adaptive optic system to
correct for that so yeah I would say
it's probably simpler at least for proof
of principle just to test it with um
with with with having some satellite
that was at a much wider orbit